well hello we're in New York now where
our show's in New York I love it here do
you love it here um I can do five or six
days that used to be me I love the
energy of this city I think that's what
I love but we're almost to Valentine's
Day and you have like one of the sexiest
voices on planet Earth so so just saying
if I'm if I'm making a Valentine's
playlist what's the song you think I
should play of yours oh oh of mine um
tonight tonight yeah good one Told You
Lately That I Love You First Cut is the
Deepest yeah oh all of those shut up
your catalog yeah I mean and and whoops
I said shut up sorry but yeah it was in
a nice way I'm it don't worry darl I'm
us you're married you I cover a lot of
Sam Cook on the show because he's one of
my favorites and I hear we have that
common yeah what's your favorite cupid
draw back to your boat change is going
to come twist in the night why do you
like lost and looking oh yes yeah yeah
yeah tremendous he was a big influence
on my career when I was growing up
that's the only guy I wanted to sound
like was Sam Cook so it's amazing to me
that you wanted to sound like anybody
other than yourself since your voice is
so magical but course but it wasn't it
didn't used to be it used to be horrible
you know but so I had some I had to mold
my voice on someone so I listened to Sam
Cook and Muddy Waters all the great
black artists yeah so there wasn't Sam
Cook there may not have been a rod
wasn't Muddy Waters no beetles yeah it's
not easy being me yeah it's well you
both have incredible voices but I love I
that's the one he's probably who I
listen to most like on vinyl when I'm
like at my Ranch oh why is only whole
lot cuz you're a country girl I Live
Well no I grew up on everything I grew
up on you I grew up on everything I'm
the last born so I was the wild one that
liked everything from Metallica to
Rosemary Clooney
to feel that's trem yeah but I feel like
we're similar because you've covered all
the great standards as well like you
like I I love all your music and I also
love when you cover other people's songs
and then it's like oh he did it better
um but what was like the first song that
moved you that you felt like it like it
stirred something in you do you remember
oh the real Deep Emotions probably
change is going to come you know um Sam
Cook and then he was killed he was
killed a few days before afterwards that
was a big moving the big one was for me
changed my life was um Bob Dylan's first
album yeah you know I'd never been to
America I had been to the other side of
the street you know and that that album
first yeah Bob Dylan's first album yeah
amazing mine was Ain't No Way artha
Franklin yeah I was like I didn't even
really understand cuz I was a kid but
even if you're a kid you understand like
a great Storyteller like I was like I
don't know what she's really talking
about but it was so moving like don't
you there yeah I love that I hear you're
making whiskey these days solid Choice
yeah it's uh it's I'm not I'm not making
it myself but I'm you know I'm I'm the
sort of face behind the bottle as it
were yeah it's really really good stuff
trust me yeah I'm going to try it you
know like a lot of whiskies you go like
that you go
oh sorry you're on the right show this
is really really acceptable and smooth
yeah I like that okay well what's the
best rock star you think that you've
hung out with while drinking whiskey um
cuz you look last time you were here you
left and I was like you have lived Seven
Lives your stories are incredible yeah
probably um my dear friend Ronnie Wood
you know we never were big whiskey
drinkers though but that I never was a
whiskey Drinker back in the day I mean I
got into it because you know I had a
Scottish father I love everything about
Scotland so it was the a natural move
for me to to to Brand a whiskey yeah
it's called Wolfies oh I like that yeah
I like I like yes I do um do you you the
band y'all want some like we're we're
all game so okay well we're GNA go over
there and we're gonna have a little
drink and we're going to judge Your
Whiskey um in the I'm just kidding we
have been highlighting buskers cuz we're
new to New York and there's a whole
thing here and I heard that early on in
your career like when you were younger
you busted is that true yeah yeah I was
bust in Paris under the Eiffel Tower and
uh in Spain in a football stadium wow
fans were coming in I just sing all the
old folk songs so that's you know I was
about 15 or 16 I suppose it's so crazy
to me to think that you were doing that
and people were like passing you like
not knowing one day you'd be you that's
insane I heard that um is this true that
a band mate that a future band me
actually discovered you on in a train
station you were playing harmonica no
this was a guy that discovered me period
um his name was Long John bgy and he had
a great blues band and I used to go and
see him and I was playing harmonica on
platform two and singing he was on
platform three and he came over and
asked me to join his band and so that's
incredible simple twist of fate yeah and
this same guy discovered Elton John was
in his band as well Long John baly is
this guy in in an anr or like working
with with a label like he seems like
he's pretty good at finding Talent he's
he's upstairs now oh man well man and
how much he blessed us with finding
y'all yeah yeah he did yeah wow what a
good ear so I heard that you keep saying
oh I'm leaving Rock behind for right now
I don't know sir that that's ever going
to happen like when you show up and you
just rock and roll you just oo it yeah
it's not much else I could have been
with his face no it's just you're so
cool I mean even like musically like I
think it's rock and roll to just be like
hell with that I'm going to sing
whatever I want
I that you're doing swing right this is
awesome this always been like a AAL
genre that you yeah the first question
first I haven't left Rock behind I'm
just I want to get on with these the
Jazz album that I've made the swing
album yeah of course I did the Great
American song book so I want to be able
to go and sing those songs absolutely
well sir rod worked with another very
talented musician on the new album let's
bring him out right now he is a
legendary band leader composer pianist
and television host everybody please say
hello to Jules
[Applause]
[Music]
Holland you look very swinging man I
love this whole vibe you're I'm TR to go
as swing as I possibly can exactly yeah
it's so nice to be here with this
amazing man isn't it I know well I'm
going to start with that how did this
happen like how did y'all end up doing
this did you want to start or I'll start
I was trying to make this swing album in
Los Angeles and it wasn't turning out so
well cuz it wasn't didn't have enough
Edge to it I wanted it a bit bit more
rock and roll yeah bit scruffy so I
thought of him yes he said he said he he
said I want something Rough and Ready
said well thank you you've come to the
right man Rough and Ready cuz it's I
think this many jokes there yes thank
you yes um as I said earlier if there's
any inuendo I like to whip it out
straight away okay um so I think one of
the things that I really couldn't
believe was that Rod rang me just before
Christmas and I listen our paths had
crossed occasionally in music but I
didn't know him so well and he rang and
said could you come and um uh make do
you want to make a record with me one
and happy Christmas so I said yeah great
thanks a lot and that was he said I'll
call you next year I thought it was a
hoax call but then in the new year he
rang again it was absolutely true and he
said I want something but I mean it's
hard to put words on music but it's all
those great songs but have got sort of a
little rock and roll edgy tattin to them
that's not the right word but it's the
feeling you get off them that's the Tess
was pretty nice it was all words that
applied to me I think so um us them he
used them and so uh it's and I was very
worried when we first did it and we we I
recorded the first tracks or got them
ready and then he came in and he started
dancing and then I knew everything
everything was going to be okay but
that's what's so beautiful about swing
in general is you have to move you feel
the music as well even if you're singing
it or playing it it's just it moves you
and I think that joy in music sometimes
gets lost that's exactly the word joy
and there's not so much a lot of music
doesn't have joy in it and this music
really does doesn't it it's the most and
it's been a very happy experience
normally you hear about records people
say oh you know we we we had a fight in
the studio I've left music because of it
it was the worst experience of my life
this is the opposite it's been a
pleasure it's been so easy because it's
all the we love the songs and and it's
an expression of Joy so great is it is
it true that yall did most of it live in
the studio like with the I love that
I've only done that like a few times and
God it is amazing to be in a studio and
feel that that's the way bands that's
the way music used to be recorded you
know even in the 50s and 60s was all
done live but uh the only thing that
wasn't live was my vocal I had to have a
few goes on it get used to the song
otherwise it was all live that's
incredible sounds it too I there is such
a different sound and you've been doing
swing for quite some time yes I mean my
I was in Span squeeze and I left and I
started a big band in England and I
realized um you know I had the ability
to make people dance early on I think
you know I mean all great musicians or
great singers Rod connects any song
that's a great thing and I think if
you're me and a a piano player you've
got to be able to make people dance as
well um we did um as an example early on
in the '90s when we my big band first
got together we had a show where we did
for the G8 which is all the leaders of
the western world so at that time it was
President Clinton prime minister Blair
and all of the others and we got to do
it and we decided pressure no pressure
that's right exactly the world's
watching and a lot of security but uh we
thought we' better end with a song that
unifies everybody so we did All You Need
Is Love so we play the trumpet player
plays at which point the French
President thinks that's a French
national anthem so he stands up so then
I'm thinking oh it's and then Blair and
Clinton both out of politeness they
stand up cuz it's a French national
emous sort of doing this then it goes
into all you need is love but to avoid
an incident and I don't know which one
started it and credit to him whichever
one started it he starts they all start
doing this a bit of dad dancing really
it was Dad dancing oh my God I was I
thought you were going to be like so we
broke out with the French Anthem and
I knew it didn't bother no no but it was
great and after all if all the worlds
dance if they're all dancing we laughing
aren't we you know oh my God that's
hilarious what a great story and I would
be sweating if I were you to be like who
knows the
anthem
[Music]
a a mood I'm in why it's almost like
being in
love there's a smile on my face follow
all human race why it's almost almost
like being in
love
love we are back with sir Ric Stewart
and
Jin so once again we were speaking of
the joy it brings people was that like
impromptu like did you all like decide
you just going to show none of those
people look like they knew y were going
to be there no we didn't know we were
there yeah it was a railway station in
Russia and we just turned up plugged in
and started playing I love it back to
your busking I like it more or less yes
quite right there that's amazing you see
how much joy you were talking about that
ear and everybody's just feeling it but
also that song you see that of all all
the songs on this record we talked about
like I think of some think we just loved
all of the song this is the one song
that I didn't know I mean you can't know
everything can you it's the one song I
didn't know but when as soon as he
starts singing it it became my favorite
song you're a great singer you know this
but it's when the singer makes you
realize it's the singer not the song and
he's the great singer and that's that's
this was a particular special moment
when he first sang
that so you're so you're saying that for
the most part you all agreed on songs or
did you each kind of bring your own
favorites to the table favorites to the
table Yeah we know there are no
arguments oh I love that we could have
made another album straight away there's
so much great music yeah we and we both
spent a long time live listening to and
loving a lot of these are great old
American songs a couple of them Old
English songs but most of them are great
old American songs and we've grown up
with all of that hadn't we and just Lov
them what was one that you like were
like this has to be on the album what
was that song for me yeah uh the first
track um laabi Broadway oh I don't know
that one yeah come on long and listen
to I do
know oh man I don't even I don't think I
knew the name of it but yes barley what
was the movie uh gold diggers in 193
yeah yeah when you s grape Digger a
minute ago my brain said Gold Digger and
I was like you were a what like
literally that's where my brain went I
was like I mean you're owning it okay I
was like good for you um but anyway you
said Grave Digger I heard this crazy
story I don't know if it's true but it's
about yes with you with sod so the first
time you saw the Rolling Stones they
were doing blues music at like a little
was it like a pub or theater what was
what was it oh a place called ilai
Island there was a little Ballroom in
Twickenham and there was 12 people there
12 people 12 people and mix girlfriend
was a girl called Chrissy shrimpton
who's a sister of the great model Jean
shrimpton and my girlfriend his
girlfriend were friends and he said come
and see my singer my boyfriend he's a
singer said my boyfriend's a singer too
so I went over there and watched and
there was literally nobody there and
they were all sitting on stools playing
you know but they were doing like blues
music yeah oh yeah yeah Brian Jones was
in the band in and then in within six
months to a year bash that was it they
took off I mean yeah those moments are
just so cool like once again like you
busking and people not knowing and then
you sitting there and not knowing like
what that band would become yeah the
Blues in Britain was a big thing that's
where that's where I started as well
playing clubs playing Blues stuff cuz
that's what we all heard it was a thing
we you know that you got makes such an
impact yeah like here like there's a lot
of music it just let's do for fun but
not much that I mean feels like really
moves you yeah or that's what I like to
listen to but you do you think you'll go
back to Vegas with this album I'm just
finished up in Vegas my last I've done
200 shows so in August that's it you
that's a lot of shows 200 yeah and
you're going to do shows with Billy Joel
as well I'm doing a show with Billy Joel
Billy Jones's asked me to join him on
show that's
amazing in September at the Cleveland
Browns uh Stadium that's oh my gosh but
yeah I love I love Vegas love going
there the people at Caesar's Palace are
just wonderful it's the best place you
could see anybody best seats the best
sound intimate isn't it it's intimate it
feels like no I agree I love and I love
play there yes and I love I love going
back to my favorite like whether you're
in a stadium or an arena or whatever my
favorite is always a more intimate like
five or less 5,000 or less is my
favorite I know that's you play five
million but I play like less and I like
I like that though even like in the days
when I was like doing cing G like
everywhere and there were thousands of
people everywhere it's just so much
better for me as a performer if it's
more intimate and like a theater
environment and you feel like you're
like talking with people I don't know I
feel like it's kind of cool yeah it is
yeah absolutely smaller places are
better but they don't pay the bills
yeah I am
aware I am aware uh let's hear it one
more time everybody for Jules Holland
andon Stewart the new album is called
swing fever you can find it wherever you
get your music starting February
[Music]
23rd
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home